avant dès le troisième sujet de cinq
minutes inside je suis le retour de
style classera que la semaine dernière
les audiences ont été en baisse hier et
en parallèle nous avons souvent évoqué
le sujet vincent lagaf dans tpm p suite
à ses déclarations sur tf1 et moi je
pense que vous avez été et voilà dit la
vérité est ce que vous pensez que vous
avez été responsable de la mort
elle va vous faire un petit récap de
l'émission d'hier soir regardez bas
serait s'est passé et vous avez vous
dire si oui ou non vous trouvez
responsable la petite chute d'eau douce
est partie soir vincent lagaf présentait
un nouveau numéro de strike spéciale
années 80 un petit résumé ça vous dit ah
oui au programme des tubes des années 80
[Applaudissements]
mais surtout des stars des années 80
qu'on était bien content de revoir joly
[Applaudissements]
sabrina
sabrina qui nous a donné des petits
cours d'italien et on a appris plein de
choses
ce dj lethal adam le bowling chose
bowling une sabrina très doué en langues
un peu moins beau ligne
[Applaudissements]
c'est ta faute pourquoi heureusement
patrick hernandez était là pour remonter
le niveau
et pour chapeauter le toit l'animation
vincent lagaf qui sait mettre à l'aise
ses invités est ce que tu te rends
compte qu'un jour dans ta vie tu seras
moche quoi aussi bilan d'audience pour
strike hier soir 4 149 mille
téléspectateurs
alors messieurs maxime gagné alors moi
et je voulais dit et je vois là j'ai des
fonds du vinson c'est vrai que voilà
mais vous avez je vous laisse dire ce
que vous voulez vous avez dire c'est moi
qui produit l'émission
et c'est vrai qu'il y en avait eu une
petite baisse d'audience j'espère que ça
va remonter et je pense que le jeu
vraiment bien et vincent octobre dedans
que ça mais est ce que vous sentez
responsable ma part je suis convaincu
que les deux débats qu'on a pris icône a
tenus sur vincent lagaf cette semaine
dans tpm paix ont n'ont pas porté
emporté un vraiment préjudice au
programme on s'est tiré un peu la balle
dans le pied en possède une collection
maison mois c'est long c'est une
production maison est ce qu'on sait dire
j'ai vu ensuite
suite à notre débat des boycotts des
tweetos et de foehn tout ce qu'elle
voulait pu regarder les questions à
cause de ce qu'on avait dit de vincent
lagaf
c'est ce qu'a dit et qu'il y ait
également mais le programme n'est pas à
remettre en cause ou alors j'aimerais la
dalle xingu qui est un petit peu
extérieur vous qu'est ce que vous en est
ce que vous avez pensé que l'équipe de
tmp est un petit peu responsable de la
chute d'audience
ben en ce moment je sens qu'il ya
beaucoup de polémiques et un petit
acharnement c'est dommage je trouve que
c'est vite fait des supers chose vincent
lagaf a une très bonne popularité
maintenant il ya un problème de match
donc il faudrait que vous voilà que ce
soit mme louka place est important parce
qu'on aime beaucoup être tous sur le
même bateau et on sent qu'il ya de la
non moi je vous dis la vérité parce que
je pense que je connais la vérité avec
avec lagaf qui s'est passé c'est que il
ya eu les mois un concours de miss you
kate entre vous et la gaffe la vérité
elle est là c'est qu'il est arrivé sur
ces 8,2 ici c'est une grande et la plus
grosse du ctu way s'est tue c'est une
grosse vedette
je n'ai moi même vécu qu'on change
migros va naître je suis arrivé sur eux
sur sur s'éviter maintenant en trois ans
pour faire de même style pour vous
remplacer
j'ai moi même refusé comme la guerre à
l'époque de fer chroniqueur dans tpm
pêche fep a proposé à vincent lui a dit
de tout de suite qu'il n'irait pas dans
cette émission mais c'est pas le même
problème s'est poursuivie comme lui à
cette époque faso je fais ce que je veux
suivre d'être la différence c'est que
j'ai compris ahmed époque que les
vedettes sur s'est vite c'est hanouna et
que non quand même ces supports côté là
julien ça mais voilà et qu' il tenté le
fight avec vous c'est stupide parce que
vous avez une base de fans qui est très
importante et qu'évidemment commandant
l'émission ont fait des remarques
évidemment je pense qu'il ya un boycott
et ça a des conséquences l'erreur de et
je vous dis je finis là-dessus l'erreur
de de vincent allez allez allez simple
il fait une émission suite ici 15
émissions sur ces 8 alors ici il a un
peu parlé de ce trail candidats envoyé
deux belles équipes
heures il a parlé de deux secondes de ce
trac et de ce qu'ils voulaient faire
ailleurs et ça je vous le dis très
clairement ça n'a pas plu aux gens et
c'est rennes en battant mais ça c'est
moche mais ça n'a rien à voir avec avec
ça aurait été pareil sur n'importe quoi
non plus que les téléspectateurs sont
très attachés aussi voilà à telle ou
telle chaîne et que la voilà ils se sont
dit mais enfin ça il ne devrait pas
méchamment je voulais dire parvenir si
vous avez suivi un petit peu la faire
c'est vrai que les chroniqueurs n'ont
pas été tendres avec vincent lagaf
je vous ai trouvé je vous dis un petit
peu dur parce que voilà il a dit voilà
qui avait envie de faire un truc de
sports mécaniques sur tf1 et vous avez
été un petit peu dur donc je vous
demande et je vous pose la question et
je vous pose la question aussi à vous
est-ce que les chroniqueurs est-ce que
voilà et tpm puisque je me mets dedans
est responsable de la baisse d'audience
de strike alors vous pour moi pas du
tout aller lui c'est la gaffe qui est
responsable et vous vous êtes toujours
maintenant je vous le dis il a créé les
conditions du divorce et s'est éloigné
des gens il n'ya aucun divorce en mai à
raison avec le public avec vous la
rupture
peut-être provisoire pour moi il ne peut
pas faire autrement que de s'excuser en
second jeu mathieu alors dire quelque
chose que vous que vous le vouliez ou
non c'est la vérité ne me coupe pas la
parole
chen s'est totalement c'est totalement
construit encore si vous êtes pour rien
autour de vous autour d'une sorte de
fans baisse comme ça qui fait qu'il ya
un million de millions de personnes peu
importe selon les prévenus c'est autour
de vous donc c'est comme ça les gens
viennent sur cette chaîne man
principalement pour vous et ensuite vous
souvenez vous c'est parce qu'ils me donc
son camp suite de ça lui un pas
forcément hisser mis le patron à douille
ses mille et celui que les gens aiment à
dos comme effectivement tu l'avais fait
une allure dès que tu critiques syrie le
culte mais cyrille adoula crédit qu'est
ce qui te fous de moi c'est vrai que tu
le veuilles ou non c'est comme ça et lui
c'est ce qu'il a fait il sait me cyril
hanouna dos et la chaîne cyril la menace
est bavard et bas normands les gens sont
pressés de dire quand c'est une cyril
hanouna d'où je m'entends très bien mais
vous avez bouclé et vous écris tout ça
passe
qu'est ce qu'il a dit elle s'avère
malgré l'ajout dixit et a fallu propose
un truc plus gros et va durer sur tf1 si
vous ne voyez pas de corrélation entre
le fait qu' il vient ici se comporte pas
très très bien dans l'émission n'est pas
très très bien avec vous et derrière sa
démission a pas d'un million à 300 mille
personnes c'est franchement qu'on est
homophobes à glee géraldine et hoarau
crevier moi je pense que la gaffe a fait
du mal à la gaffe que lagaf a besoin de
personne pour se saboter et ans et je
pense que les chroniqueurs n'y sont pour
rien parce que je trouve qu'il ya eu
quand même une sorte de dichotomie et je
pense que les téléspectateurs le centre
de na waie alors il ya une sorte de
comment dire de séparation emballé les
dichotomies et une dichotomie entre le
lagaf l'animateur sorte d'ambiance il
m'a fait la blogging à l'écouté moi
c'est super important
le côté animateurs club de bowling bip
bip super jeu mais l'ambiance et tout ça
et le côté homme d'affaires un peu
business pas corporate et les
téléspectateurs le ressentent ce sorte
de dualité comme ça de schizophrénie
vous vous avez une sorte de grand bordel
en vous vous avez les bons côtés des
mauvais côtés
non mais vous êtes globalement le même
vous dites ce que vous aimez vous disent
que vous aimez pas vous gueulez il ya
des jours avec et des jours sans
c'est clair net et précis et les gens je
pense m cette aspérité là la gaffe c'est
pas clair je trouve que c'est pas net et
je trouve que c'est pas apprécié le goût
des mots je trouve voilà je trouve qu'on
ait tout futur mois donc on est un petit
peu dure deux minutes au 8e minute et
isabelle louis sûrs et moi je pense que
peut-être qu'il ya les les fans 12 comme
on a dit comme a dit maxime qu'on
compile une part de responsabilité mais
il a commencé à 900000 la gaffe d'un
million un camion il se retrouve à trois
cent mille juifs parce que nous on a dit
ok c'est pas bon ce qui la veille n'aura
pas de sysiphe le plateau est beau le
bowling c'est magnifique a amené aux
gens mais si c'est mal présenté ces
mâles présents
là dedans quand blanche a fait un
spectacle sur s'est vite elle fait elle
fait du surplace en nous ça veut dire
que si demain vous partez de ces vite
demain vous partez c'est fini y'a du
film vient pas du tout c'est pas du tout
ici heureusement alors lâche ni sa ferme
pas du tout il trouve vraiment quelqu'un
pour moi passer je suis sûr que c'est
vite va perdurer bien après mon départ
voilà et si les mâchoires wii voit comme
moi je connais vincent lagaf bolat - là
d'un ami et je le reconnais pas dans ce
que vous dites c'est un garçon sincère
franc
bon ça et alors quand on s'appelle lagaf
et qu'on fait la gaffe bon il a fait une
gaffe
voilà c'est ça devient alors bat pas on
va mal assurée à cause des femmes
mais je n'ai pas la tête je pense pas
cher mathieu qu'il faut s'excuser d'être
soi même et on peut se tromper dans la
grézère pourra pas s'excuser d'être soi
même
maintenant ce que je pense sur le
bowling c'est que y'a peut-être pas une
culture bowling en france quand tu
regarde toi tu regarde par exemple un
film extraordinaire comme le big
lebowski oui où tout est basé autour du
bowling je pense que vincent il a voulu
faire un truc comme ça et moi je pense
peut-être que 25 faudra it il faudrait
qu'ils repensent un petit peu son son sa
ligne éditoriale pour le royaume est
quelque chose je serai non mais non mais
vu foncer non mais je dis que là tu
quand tu regardes the big lebowski la
façon dont tu pouvais mais acteurs
vivent le bowling peut-être qu'il faut
un peu plus de acting et petit peu voilà
peut-être qu'il faut qu'ils repensent un
tout petit peu on va licencier
la gaffe à pas ses mots on attendait la
gare ce débat là je vois ce qu'on
pensait téléspectateurs merci tpm pee
wee à 56,8 en eau pour les télés restent
on arrive à merci
l'afrique